mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
sie ist die konstanz des schweizer
fotojournalismus pia zanetti als frau
war sie eine pioniere
es ist schwierig so engagiert und
respektvoll begegnete sie den menschen
das hätte würde ob es hier dauerte
letztlich kalt immer mehr haben würde
mehr von pia zanetti gleich jetzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir kommen auf dem kurplatz wir machen
heute station in der fotostiftung
winterthur und möchten ihn von hier aus
das werk von pia zanetti vorstellen eine
überaus engagierte fotografin die sich
vor über 60 jahren in einer männerdomäne
durchbeißen musste nun gibt es hier in
winterthur eine große ausstellung zu
ihrem werk ja und pia zanetti hat viel
zu erzählen von ihrem fotografischen
schaffen und auch aus ihrem bewegten
leben ich freue mich auf diese begegnung
schön sind sie mit dabei
[Musik]
internet das ist ein großer moment sie
sind die richter für ihre ausstellung im
fotomuseum winterthur als wunderschönes
buch user mit ihrem werk mit ihrem
schaffen ist jetzt also zieht zum ernten
zu viel ernte ist es und vier monate
geduld weil es ist einfach zu
beschäftigt wie alle museen und militär
ab und am gleichen aber es ist
hoffnungslos gotten und dem freue ich
mich sehr dass das geht ja für rücken
und das finde ich sehr schön dass jetzt
durch die rumlaufen werde ich stelle mir
richtig ist an frankreich als ganzes
lebenswerk
das ist hoch emotionalen sie haben das
ist es wirklich will
es ist halt hinter jeder vierte jetzt
riesige geschichte jetzt problemlos
verzichten wenn sie hat eigentlich
keiner begegnung fotografische werk also
das titelbild ist eigentlich begegnen
wir seri druck gemacht hat weil es ist
ein musical wir haben nach dem weg fragt
die frau während gezeigt und sich für
mich ein symbol vor der wahl kann zeigt
[Musik]
ihre bilder sind nie neutral immer
nehmen sie stellung im zentrum stets der
mensch in seiner umgebung mit seinen
teils prekären lebensbedingungen
politisch sozial humanistisch so sieht
sich pia zanetti selbst ihr hunger mehr
zu sehen und zu erleben führt die
gebürtige baslerin bis in die
entlegensten und unwirtlichsten winkel
der erde acht jahre lebt sie in rom und
london legt die grundstein für den
späteren erfolg
mit ihrem mann dem journalisten girardot
zanetti realisiert sie eine vielzahl von
reportagen für international renommierte
zeitschriften
obwohl keine people fotografen hat sie
doch einige prominente vor der kamera
die modeschöpferin vivienne westwood
regisseur federico fellini
schauspielerin bette davis
order den boxer muhammad ali in seinem
auto eine zufällige begegnung in den
straßen von l e
dreimal insgesamt reist sie mit ihrem
mann für reportagen durch nordamerika
hält den zeitgeist fest new york 1963
schwarze frauen sichtbar
modisch da war piazza ethikrat mal 20
jährige wiederholt begibt er sich in
kriegsregionen zeigt die folgen
bewaffneter konflikte für die einzelnen
menschen die hier nicaragua ihr scharfer
blick geht in umständen wie die menschen
leben und arbeiten
ob in kenia oder ihrer
zwischenzeitlichen heimat dem tessin
diese bilder haben eine universelle
kraft höchste zeit wird pia zanetti
endlich gebührend gefeiert
[Musik]
immer wieder fotografen warten und sie
sich ganz schwierig sie lehrstellen
finden tut uns leid als junge frau ich
eine damit tragen uns gut mit und denn
eine zum in portugal eher machen das
foto auf 52 30
was sie eigentlich nicht will aber dass
er nicht gemacht weil er einfach mit
abschlägen sind auch eigentlich habe
erste fragen wir überhaupt sieber als
fotoreporterin und rack switches ausland
gegangen
nach italien zieht für erfahrungen ja es
ist einfach wirklich weit und breit die
einzige frau bin ich seh und damit das
gleiche wort eine bösartige schmunzeln
und die paparazzi weiter unter wachsen
sie natürlich kasten von anderen es ist
schwierig sie will die tour ab mit denen
mal ans klo weiter und ich heute bist
und so sie hat in rom auch schweizer
größeren betroffen wie zum beispiel max
frisch was sind das wir begehen
das ist natürlich für mich ganz mit
unglaublichem respekt godfather jetzt
gestärkt worden sind haben also was das
was er gemacht hat und damals mit dem
neu und frisch pyro taxi und die ist in
unserem alter und diese oft sie und
dänische freundschaft eigentlich
besondere durch sie aber als
distanzierter menschen kann man
vielleicht da ihrem buch kurz nach
eintreffen wo sie haben keine
fotografieren zwischen dem thüringer und
frisst 2 was ich hier eigentlich nicht
so nächsten jahr wenn du das ist trafik
sie fotogruppe 740 verlässliche maus in
prag
und da haben sich schriftsteller tropfen
und frisch und dürrenmatt sind zusammen
gesessen und die haben mir gar nicht
sehen und haben sicher lustig nach der
über das burgund damals loshaben der
frist gesehen und hätte den knochen
und es gibt zwar schnitt dass die beiden
so noch zusammen sind weil dir das
gipfelkreuz amt
[Musik]
vor zehn jahren begann der arabische
frühling junge menschen verlangt nach
freiheit und nach politischer öffnung in
ägypten haben damals berichtet über die
aktivisten in kairo und heute fragen wir
was ist aus ihnen und aus ihren
hoffnungen geworden
es gibt orte die klinge nach freiheit
nach auf hunger
nach veränderung sie markieren einen
einschnitt in der geschichte wie der
tahrir platz in kairo
hier war das zentrum der ägyptischen
revolution vor zehn jahren auch li na
hat allah demonstrierte damals auf dem
tahrir-platz gegen das regime mubarak
die journalistin die heute maße das
einzige unabhängige nachrichtenportal
ägyptens leitet wurde letztes jahr vom
time magazin auf die liste der 100
einflussreichsten personen gesetzt
[Musik]
für mich bedeutet der platz sehr viel
näher als nur 2011 das ist der ort wo
ich politisch aktiv wurde wo ich begann
journalistin zu sein
auf dem platz habe ich schon 2003 den
protest gegen den irakkrieg erlebt
dieser platz zeugt von meinem
politischen bewusstsein von meiner
politischen entwicklung
es ist auch ein platz der bilder die
unvergessen bleiben
ein toter demonstrant wird von einem
polizisten einfach am straßenrand
entsorgt
[Musik]
für ihn wurde der tahrir-platz zur
großen bühne
ramy essam verwandelte die parolen der
revolte in music hall ihre ab hau ab
mubarak sang er
heute lebt ramy essam in skandinavien im
exil geflohen vor der brutalität des
neuen regimes geflohen vor dem militär
ich bin immer noch derselbe und ich kann
es kaum erwarten eine zweite chance zu
bekommen ja wieder auf der straße zu
demonstrieren um fortzusetzen was wir
damals begonnen haben und ich glaube
stark daran dass ich nicht der einzige
bin der einzige ist er nicht barca das
online magazin berichtet kritisch über
politik und menschenrechtsverletzungen
in ägypten obwohl die regierung ständig
versucht kritischen journalismus mundtot
zu machen war dermaßen wird im netz
blockiert und kann nur über umwege
gelesen werden wir haben ständig das
gefühl dass der spielraum in dem wir uns
journalistisch bewegen ganz schnell
verschwinden kann
wir könnten verhaftet werden
im gefängnis landen oder den laden
komplett schließen müssen es gibt keinen
raum mehr um die grenzen auszuloten
gegen die wir kämpfen
es ist mehr das gefühl alles riskieren
zu müssen
als gäbe es kein morgen sturz des
regimes mubarak
der tahrir-platz heute mit aller macht
hat das jetzige regime den platz
umgestaltet nicht so rinner nicht soll
bleiben
von den forderungen von damals vom ruf
nach brot freiheit und sozialer
gerechtigkeit
[Musik]
rami wurde zu einem star der revolte
keine demonstration ohne konzert er
kämpfte ganz vorne mit war mittendrin
und wurde zum ziel gewaltsamer
übergriffe meine gitarre ist hier und
ich werde weiter singen und dieses haus
nimmt barack zurücktritt
als mubarak trat haben wir die straßen
platz verlassen
die leute dachten das ist erledigt wir
haben den diktator verjagt iran naiv zu
glauben dass mubarak das problem dar
später mussten wir feststellen dass
nicht er das problem war sondern das
system das die macht des militärs war
das wirkliche problem
welche macht welche gewalt das neue
regime ausgeübt bekam ramy essam 2018 zu
spülen als in einem sony gibt es macht
habe als sie verspottet
ramy essam selbst befand sich im exil in
sicherheit
in ägypten jedoch wurde der poet
kalahari der den text geschrieben hatte
verhaftet
shadi habasch regisseur des videos kam
im gefängnis unter mysteriösen umständen
ums leben
bedauerte ramy essam dieses video
produziert zu haben
am kanal und ich etwas falsch gemacht
weil wir einen politischen song
veröffentlicht haben
nein haben wir nicht ein politischer
song darf der nicht dazu führen dass man
menschen ins gefängnis start und einen
sterben lässt nissan hat seinen freunden
im gefängnis dieses lied gewidmet der
kampf eines menschen der langsam
erstickt
[Musik]
in li na hat als reaktion hängt ein
bilderwand mit einem spruch ist nordisk
wer der tahrir platz ist mehr als ein
ort
ich gehöre zu den leuten die nicht so
nostalgisch sind was diese zeit vor zehn
jahren betrifft aber es gibt diesen
zauber das versprechen dass etwas
möglich ist wenn ich an revolution denke
während einer krise jetzt ich denke an
die brüche an die ereignisse die möglich
waren die entgleisungen der weg den wir
damals gegangen sind ist wieder möglich
und das ist das versprechen von 2011 und
der tahrir platz
er präsentiert sich zum jubiläum als das
pompös touristische gegenteil von dem
was er einmal war nichts erinnern an die
revolution die von hier aus ihren anfang
nahm
der platz hat nichts mehr mit mir zu tun
das ist ein fremder ort aber es ist okay
wir sind ja umgeben von so viel fremden
wenn ich dort vorbeikommen überquere ich
den platz einfach schnell und lebe mein
leben
pia zanetti sie sind ja als
fotoreporterin kriegs und krisengebieten
unterwegs sie unter anderem in südafrika
zu zeiten der apartheid das bild nimmt
auch der 60 entstanden
was hat sich das bild also das ist
einfach das land wenn ich so schockiert
city oder alle haben ein gewisses gegen
apartheid aber was in der realität heißt
hatte ich mir schon vorstellen und ihr
wollt ihr das sind fische dass sie wohl
auch tagsüber so austragen ist potente
und irgendwie probieren wird es zeigen
trotz seiner verletzlichkeit mehr
menschen oliven oder und da bin ich jung
sehr jung und einfach schockiert ich es
nicht fassen dass ich bin mir wirklich
gravierte das bild habe ich bei mir
daheim große frank will
es ist so dass wird bald auch noch mit
uns oder und mehr mithalten
sie haben das bild war schwarz das
hinter meinte was hinteren kleine diese
ruhe
was sind die schwarze frauen ein kind an
wie sie kinder gehörten noch nicht von
einer reichen familie weil es gilt nicht
die frau ist nicht wert die - kind her
das gilt nicht mehr seit sie schaltet
nicht weil sie sich gar nicht und das
ist wirklich einfach unvorstellbar und
schweiz
nein ich habe eigentlich nie praktischen
er augenscheinlich unter 50 nein ich bin
nicht ängstlich weil ich glaube sonst
macht mir damals nicht gemacht habe und
es ist schicksal nicht danken
ich gestehe musik
angeschoben
[Musik]
die rassentrennung in südafrika ist
längst geschichte doch rassismus ist in
unserer welt nach wie vor präsent die
black lifes matter demonstrationen im
letzten jahr haben uns alle aufgerüttelt
das führt zu einem neuen bewusstsein so
auch im film und im theater und zwar
unter dem stichwort kolle blind casting
also farbenblinde rollenbesetzung aber
hilft farbenblindheit den rassismus aus
der welt zu schaffen
wir haben nachgefragt die roben sind
opulent das setting ist historisch
england 1813 der königshof vergnügt sich
mit tratsch und klatsch über
heiratswillige junge frauen so kitschig
so historisch denkbar
doch die queen ist schwarz und der halbe
hofstatt ebenso bevölkert von
dunkelhäutigen hughes und girls
[Musik]
wie ist das möglich im eigentlich weißen
königshaus
das zauberwort heißt farben blindes
casting man ignoriert bewusst die
hautfarbe bei der besetzung von rollen
für die deutsche schauspielerin salma
burbank die am zürcher schauspielhaus
spielt ist das höchste zeit für frauen
wo man noch genau hingucken muss und
gucken muss dass man leute besetzt und
zwar in allen rollen
da musste finde ich schon dass man da
explizit gucken sollen sagen kann das
wird jetzt extra mal ein schwarzer mann
oder extra mann türkischer oder eine
planung asiatische personen die das
macht doch ist das nicht zu viel die
fabulierlust fern der geschichtlichen
realität findet man sieht es in film
oder auch andere fabelwesen frau kommen
auch auf der bühne das geht alles
drachen geht aber schwarzer könig da
gehen salma borbely spielzeit jahren im
deutschsprachigen fernsehen und oft
bestimmt nur ihre hautfarbe welche rolle
sie bekommt hat sich persönlich wieso
wieso sollte ich da gar nicht kennen
weil ich schwarz bin obwohl ich seit
meinem vierten lebensjahr in deutschland
lebe aus dem rheinland komme sogar
kölsch spreche ja also sozusagen
rheinische mädchen bin durch sich aber
wenn ich dreht habe immer nur
prostituierte dienstmädchen sklaven oder
rechts spielen oder gar kein deutscher
gebrochenes deutsch oder meisten
afrikanisch reden mit meinem kollegen
und schwarzen ist mal so wir sind
afrikanische trotz klischees das
bewusstsein people of cologne zu kasten
ist gestiegen auch wenn hauptrollen sind
doch die frage bleibt wie sinnvoll es
ist historische stoffe einer
mehrheitlich weißen geschichte mit
people of course zu besetzen
das musical hamilton zum beispiel
erzählt den gründungsmythos der usa es
ist eine reinweiße geschichte gespielt
von mehrheitlich schwarzen ist das
geschichtsklitterung oder
selbstermächtigung und auf die schweiz
bezogen kann man sich an heidi
vorstellen dunkelhäutig
[Musik]
oder einen wilhelm tell also wenn allzu
konzeptionell der tag und sondern
wirklich gut und qualität hat dann kann
ich mir sogar vorstellen dass das
publikum findet wie gratis wie wilhelm
tell und das habe ich schon hundertmal
gesehen und normal intelligent alles
lang aber wenn das so setzt wird diesen
frischen winds ich habe mir das schon
vorstellen
corinna groß ist die große casting
agenturen
sie besetzt fast alle erfolgreichen
filme in der schweiz von wolkenbruchs
wunderliche reise einer schickte bis
platzspitz baby doch people of colour
kommt nur selten vor dem platzspitz baby
war eigentlich aus wie ist es nötig sind
dann stach so super ziehen dann haben
wir halt die familie etwas zu stützen
es ist höchste zeit im zeitgenössischen
fehlen die besetzung diverser zu
gestalten
egal welche räume sind
besichtigungen im ersten moment einfach
automatisch auf wie sie manche tankt und
geht dann aber setzt mit einer farbigen
hintergrund der toten rehs an
verständlichkeit zu brechen und sich so
besser also das positive effekt der
größte kunde
es stimmt ja und das gar nicht wählen
ich leider gar nicht irgendwie ihr
gesicht und die biografie und so ich
habe sondern es ist einfach so
bei historischen figuren mag es
schwieriger sein
doch bei den regenten könnte man mal
anfangen
[Musik]
mit ihrem verstorbenen ehemann gerardo
zanetti haben sie früher mal sehr viel
fotoreportage gemacht sind auf reisen
sie hat sehr viel erlebt mehr haben
wirklich zusammen und baut ganz jung und
mehr an politisch zusammenhalt
erwartungen und was man glaubt dass man
begeistert ist von 68 hat man ja noch
einen walzer foxtrott also und wir sind
einfach den wirkliches team das
reporterteam das ist schon sehr schön
sie also werden das sehr genossen und
irgendwann haben wir dann beschlossen
dass das natürlich lieferant wird und
dann ein dahinter zusammen luft sorgen
machen ob ihre familie sind dann gibt es
dazu ein neues kapitel in ihrem buch und
das ist ihre tochter nina wo sie
adoptiert hat in vietnam vielleicht
sogar zum besten
wir haben zwei selber gemacht die finma
des motivs werkes und dennis minenwerten
am gipfel arbeit und die schöne weiße
haus gesehen und hat sehr viel verzählt
über das weiße haus und dann ich halt
auch verdanke immer wieder kurz machen
und deshalb mit uns aufwachsen und dann
haben wir beschlossen würde das machen
und dadurch normal für arbeit nach
vietnam und ist in das weiße haus zurück
und gefragt ob es überhaupt aus welle
sind wacker den atx radiologen und
hannover soll für kinder zeigt und daher
heulen des windes waren darunter hätten
einfach zu merken
bitte denkt sich da raus und das ist ein
total witzig kaiser und ich bitten was
sie zu sagen sonst gesetze mehr zusammen
nach vietnam und haben sehr viel erlebt
seine traurig und fröhlich und voller
emotionen
es ist ganz wichtige see auf und noch
ein zwerg seite 20 uhr in schwyz es ist
gut so sehr schön dass sich damit alles
teilen sind die sieben assists
klimagesetz sondern es aber nicht im
trotz zweifel jedenfalls sind sie immer
noch und immer wieder unterwegs am
fotografieren abreisen ich jetzt gar
weniger aber geht ruft auto mache ich
weiß es wirklich nicht ob ich noch
irgendein militäranlage ohne licht und
mit googles geschlafen und muss immer
wieder schöne begegnung und alles gute
mit humor denn corona widrigkeiten
trotzen das versucht das kabarettisten
duo schertenleib und jäger lena auch sie
sind gewinner unseres kultur kick
wettbewerbs
[Musik]
heute kommen die noten mit dem burgtor
jeden donnerstagabend begrüßen michelles
l und gerhard schon ihr publikum per
livestream
[Musik]
kurz vor der produktion als verbleib und
jäger lena führen sie durch ein knapp
stündiges programm dieser stream neuland
nach 20 jahren bühnenpräsenz
jetzt glaube ich komme durch die erich
bis zwei euro stück wer hier also
liierte kreiert pro sandig die neue
programmchef das ende der welt ist
zusätzlich lehrer john solo künstler pro
stream investieren sie zwei tage
vorbereitung mindestens schon die frage
welche ja nie eine mehrheit
deshalb ermöglichen die
kulturschaffenden auftritte in ihrem
programm
etwa wie hier
autor christoph siemon zu melden
ist aber so war es auch gestern hab ich
auf sie bwb mit viel geschichte so zu
mehr mut aber es ist nicht so platziert
so macht es auch cruz david manteltasche
herrschten die biografien im motto der
caritas zu stadtteil für die die haube
vitamintabletten das plastiklöffel ab
rottenegg reißverschluss schletter
kritik von börsego verschiedene
generationen vor handy aufladen kavai
weiß nicht wie sich die manteltasche
eingefügt
irgendwas verschaffen und robin mit
wirtshaus für die neue format blockieren
es ist ein erlebnis für das projekt ist
seine antwort auf den lockdown peter
schläfli seit 20 jahren geschäftsführer
im burgdorfer theater er sammelte geld
und
kann nun wenigstens etwas kultur im
renovierten haus bieten mit probiere bis
zu machen
historiker und weil mit lou reed stadt
ist die causa mel brooks glück ja
diesmal im live stream
und wenn man glaubte stunde wurde sie
jedoch musikstunde verdammen
herausfindet möglichkeit zu betroffen
upstream erreichen sie mehr menschen als
die 260 dem theaterplatz hätten aber der
produktions rhythmus lockt aus dass ich
noch nicht dafür aber mit vorstellbar
machen bis oben wird das war aber schon
ich hab ja im casino
[Musik]
das war unser ausflug in die welt von
pia zanetti eine beeindruckende frau
voller engagement ihre ausstellung ihre
werkschau steht hier auf dem programm in
der fotostiftung schweiz in winterthur
bis ende mai hoffen wir auf offene türen
nächste woche da begrüße ich sie aus
solothurn denn die solothurner filmtage
die finden auch dieses jahr statt wenn
auch ein wenig anders gleich jetzt folgt
auf sf1 die serie meine geniale freundin
bis bald und tschüss
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz belegen wir kultur
swisslos